[Music]
Thanks
how is everybody are you still tired
thanks John
so I'm gonna do how to talk to Hardware
JavaScript firmware in 30 minutes which
is a tall order so please forgive me if
I speed through some concept or if I
abbreviate like I won't go over all of
how you do firmware in JavaScript in 30
minutes this is actually kind of a hard
concept for a lot of people including
experienced engineers so if there's
anything in here that just completely
flies by that I say really fast or that
you haven't been introduced to you
before I won't probably have time for
Q&A here but please approach me
afterwards if there's something you want
to learn more about I would be delighted
to fill in the gaps on what I didn't
have time for in here so I'm kelcie as
CJ mentioned I am one of the creators of
this thing called the tehsil which you
can basically think of as a node API for
the physical world and today we're going
to solve a problem and the problem that
we're gonna solve is I want my project
to be able to tell me whether it is
oriented right-side up or if I flip it
over and it's right side down and I lost
all my probes don't worry about that
so today's talk is not about tehsil it
includes a tehsil for the sake of
convenience because I want to write my
firmware in JavaScript but this is what
it looks like to solve my problem with
tehsil I've got two node requires I say
that I'm going to use this Tussle thing
I'm going to plug in this accelerometer
module in 4a and when it gives me data
I'm going to print it out and because
acceleration as you all know is a
constant down or because gravity is a
constant downward acceleration I'll get
a different z-axis
sign negative versus positive if I'm
like this versus like that we were like
one minute into my talk so that's why
I'm not telling you about tussle today
because it's much more interesting if we
take a look further in and don't use the
api's that we've already written so what
I'm gonna do is show you the basics of
how we go from a piece of hardware like
this with this little black chip on it
the Mme 84 accelerometer how we look at
the datasheet and interpret the signals
and talk to it in order to get useful
information so if you look at the full
stack which is not in this case a mean
stack we're gonna talk today basically
from signals on a wire to zeros and ones
binary and Hexen ting information in
English and if any of you are able to
come to the workshop tomorrow I think it
might be full but essentially pay
attention because we're gonna make you
do this tomorrow so jumping right in how
talking to hardware works there are many
ways that a signal can play on a wire
you've got your analog you've got your
pulse width modulation today we're only
going to talk about digital signals and
the reason for that is a microcontroller
will typically use just a digital signal
it's very simple it's either on or it's
off right and this is the
microcontroller trip on here and that's
what it speaks is ones and zeros so we
need to figure out how to use ones and
zeros to convey more information than
just on and off because we only have
that very simple information we have to
add the third dimension of time right
and take you all are probably familiar
with Morse code what we use as
communication protocols so a toggle ones
and zeroes with specific timing on
specific wires in encoding so that
create messages that are more complex so
for example over here in this diagram
this is using a
wrote a call called spy which we aren't
going to use for this accelerometer but
it's got four different wires clock one
that talks from the master device to the
slave device I apologize for the
terminology it's like ingrained in here
but it means that this device has
complete control and this device has no
control and so we've got one where the
master device talks to the slave and one
where the slave device responds to the
master and this other line which I won't
go into right now different protocols
use different numbers of wires and
different specific and coatings so let's
try one so this is a different one this
is called UART also known as serial and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna send
the words hello world over the wire here
hold on I lost all my probes when I
picked this up so you get to watch me
painfully attach this
alright so cereal is a protocol that
uses two wires and the third wire is
just ground which you need in everything
so by the way the device that I'm
hooking in is called a logic analyzer
and this is a really nice one it's by
this company called sale ei and what a
logic analyzer does is it lets you have
a look specifically at what the signals
are saying on the pins so you actually
get to watch and record the message is
that it's sending and it even does stuff
like interpret it and I'll show you in a
second
I think that's come on
sorry Hardware on stages like this at
the best of times there we go alright so
what I'm going to do essentially what
we're taking is a a message and we're
sending it from the tehsil and
communicating it outward and in this
case I don't even have a microchip
attached to it so it's not communicating
with anything except for this logic
analyzer here and the important bit is
what I'm showing here is this is the
JavaScript code I'm going to send and
this stuff over here is settings in the
logic analyzer which is over here
which tell it how to interpret it and
the important part is that they match
right so here we've got data bits 8 baud
rate this is the speed at which it's
sent and you can see that we've got the
same baud rate at 8 bits etc if we had
more time I'd tell you what those mean
but it honestly doesn't matter very much
in this context so what I'm going to do
is run this code and at the same time
I'm going to capture it and so this is
going to wait for something to happen
over on the tehsil and I've set it so
that when channel 3 which is this orange
wire goes high it'll
collecting samples so it's found my
tussle and it's writing and it's running
and oh oh something's not connected oops
that's what you get uploaded in
backwards
I'll try that again
right connected writing running waiting
for trigger and it took samples perfect
so I can pause it early and so what you
can see here is we've got this async
serial wine something happened to start
it so that was the initialization of the
code when I required tehsil and if we
zoom way in we can see that some up and
down motion happened and that's the ones
and zeros and if you zoom even further
in you probably can't read this very
well because this program doesn't let
you change font sizes but it says hello
world and I will take a screenshot and
let you see and bigger yeah so that's
pretty cool right now I've seen how you
can take ones and zeros and really
obscure looking bits like this and over
a wire talk to something getting back to
our problem solving so we want to
determine whether this is upside down or
right side up right so I mentioned this
earlier very briefly but the easiest
thing to do to determine right side up
and upside down is to find gravity one
of the fun bits about working with
hardware is that you get to choose your
different sensors right so you could do
this in a bunch of different ways you
could have some kind of electronic level
or you could have some like magnetic
switch that teaches it what's
upside-down up right side up you could
have a light sensor that gets covered if
it gets flipped over but what I've
decided is the most reliable and what
your smartphone manufacturers have also
decided this the right answer is an
accelerometer because you can very
consistently get the direction of
gravity right so in your smartphone it's
the thing that lets your phone know
whether it's portrait or landscape it's
just an accelerometer finding gravity so
we're gonna do that use an accelerometer
and because I want to use JavaScript and
because maybe in the future I want my
project to have internet connect
I'm gonna write on a tehsil - so how do
I actually do that so I've taken this
thing here so this is my accelerometer
module which is tehsils but what I'm
actually gonna try and talk to is this
little black chip and if you look really
close on it in tiny tiny font which you
definitely can't read it says Mme 84
which is it's part number and this whole
red board is what's called a breakout
board and it just makes it easier for it
to get plugged in and it's got a couple
of resistors and capacitors that it can
handle charge so it can have the right
address which will talk to you a bit so
what we're looking at is that little
back black bit and as you can see here
it looks like this and it has this
datasheet it's pretty cool hardware bits
come with manuals in the general case
what's sort of unfortunate and also nice
is that it's a 54 page document that you
have to look through and the thing is
you actually have to read the whole
thing if you're gonna do this stuff it's
a really good idea to actually read the
entire data [ __ ] sheet I won't make you
read the entire thing but I'll show it
to you here and we're gonna reference it
during this talk there's a bunch of
different stuff in here it talks about
you know here's what each of the
different pins do it's got a table of
contents it tells you exactly how it's
gonna work
talking about earth gravity which we've
talked about ourselves basically
everything you could possibly want to
know about this part is supposed to be
in this document so the first thing you
want to figure out is how does this talk
to this and this is looking for our
communication protocol so we already saw
cereal we saw spy
this one has i2c and how do I know that
because it says so in the table of
contents so I know that I need I to see
then I need to talk from the JavaScript
side so I go to Tesla dot io / Docs and
it redirects over here a look in
Hardware API and find I to see right so
we need to be able to specify from both
directions
so that as remember when we had the the
baud rate remember when we had the baud
rate of one one five two hundred and
eight data bits and all that sort of
stuff
we need the same sort of stuff for ITC
but a little different because it's a
different protocol so in the case of I D
I to see each hardware thing will have a
built in address and in this case the
address is in this case the address for
the accelerometer which you can find the
datasheet but I won't dig through it for
the sake of your time is 0 x1 D so we're
then going to initialize I to C is a new
I to seaport on port a and we're gonna
do the very first thing that you
typically will do is that there should
be a Who am I so this is a this is a
thing that lets you say well I've hooked
it up correctly and my software
communication is set to the appropriate
levels right so I've just plugged in the
accelerometer on port a and I'm going to
need to move this over to read on this
the i2c lines which are SCL and SDA one
of them is clock and the other one is
data
make a really confused face if you're
lost okay you all see them either fine
or asleep
okay cool so I'm gonna do the hello
world for this particular part which is
not writing the words hello world onto
it but actually looking for this thing
called Who am I
which you can find in the datasheet one
of the most useful bits of the datasheet
is this thing called register
descriptions and it tells me if I want
to get different kinds of data like
status or out X or out Z or Who am I it
says that the address of the register
that has that information is here at 0
at X 0 D and it should return
information and in this case it'll
always just return 0 X 2 a that's just
what this particular device says so I'm
going to ask it to tell me
I'm going to ask it to tell me what is
at that zero X zero D and we expect the
answer to be zero X to a so it's
connected it's running it's looking for
a trigger and it's sampling cool so
let's go find it
ah here we are some things happened this
one says zero X to a cool and it says to
weigh over here as well because I told
it to excellent so we know that our
seller ometer hooked up correctly let's
get this back so we know our
accelerometer is hooked up correctly and
we're able to talk to it so that was the
first time that the tehsil here has
talked to this little Mme 84 device on
here and this talked back to it so
communications working so back to the
problem we know that we only need the
z-axis and this is this little image of
on the side here is from the datasheet
and it says that if it's upside down
you'll get a negative Z and if it's
right side up you'll get a positive Z so
how do we learn whether the Z is
negative or positive well we're gonna
look these are copied and pasted from
the datasheet so this is the out z
there's two of them that say out see and
there's MSB and LSB and that stands for
most significant and lis significant
bits maybe those of you with classical
computer science education already know
these things but most significant bits
are gonna be the like if you had a
hundred or if you had 123 the most
significant part of that would be the
100 and the least significant would be
the 3 right so since we only care about
the negative versus positive we'll
expect this to be in the most
significant digit and specifically
there's this thing called two's
complement which according to the
datasheet is what this device with this
Mme 84 accelerometer device uses and
two's complement which I'm going to
grossly simplify right here
is a way to say negative versus positive
by using the most significant bit as a
placeholder for a negative or positive
service a negative or positive sign
right so if it's a 1 there is a minus
sign present and if it's a 0 there's no
minus sign present there's more to two's
complement but that's the important bit
for this demo so in this case the most
significant bit is bit 7 and if bit 7
gives us back a 0 then it is positive
and if it's 7 is 1 then we have a
negative number ok so let's start with
we need to read out Z MSB so if we look
back at the registers here this one it
says out z the most significant bits are
located at 0 X 0 5 so so far so good
we'll go we've got the same stuff up
here now we're looking at different
register to read we only need the one
register and within an interval of one
second we're going to ask it for that
register ok and usually I'd like to do a
demo here that shows you the importance
of reading the datasheet if I ran this
as it is I would get this repeating
value over here of 94 no matter how I
move this around whether it flip it
upside down or not
and that is because I didn't read the
part where it says oh the system is in a
low power mode when you turn it on so
you actually have to tell it to start
reading data for it to start reading
data read the datasheet that's the moral
we'll skip to it and all you have to do
there is you get this diagram that says
go to the control register and set the
active bit to one of course and so you
go google around in the or a search
around in the datasheet and you find
this thing called the control register
and set the active bit to one so let's
go ahead and do that so we've got the
same stuff we had before right that
active interval address route to read
but before that we're gonna do this set
active where we send the buffer that
says of these 8 bits set the last one
to be one great zealot good you look
good great
so what we're expecting right now and
I'll take these off we don't need them
anymore
what we're expecting right now is that
if I take this device and I have it one
way and then I move it another way we're
gonna get different data coming out oh
and if we go back to the console here
you can see that in fact data looks
different if I've got upside or if I've
got it right side up it looks pretty
similar over here I flip it over
something different is happening so
that's good what is that what is that
number so the system's awake we're
getting data what we haven't done is
interpreted the 8 bits that we get back
for just this first bit what we're
seeing right now is the number created
if you interpret the for the top eight
most significant bits as a number which
turns into a hex value which is the same
as it yeah don't worry about it what we
need to do is isolate whether or not
this first bit is a 0 or a 1 and we're
gonna do some sort of weird trick here
where we need to find out if the number
that we get back is bigger than 0 1 1 1
1 1 11 because anything bigger than that
is gonna have to have a 1 in the most
significant digit you asked me about
this later if it's confusing to you this
was like a weird mental trick for me but
basically that's isolating whether this
is a 0 or a 1 and so we'll be able to
print out if it is a 1 here then we know
it's negative and if it's a 0 here we
know it's positive so t2 run oh 7
I'd like to encourage you again if I I
think I might actually have time to take
questions at the end here which is great
so please if I have confused you here
please raise your hand and let me know
so we're getting a result and this says
positive right-side up and yeah cool so
it works and I'm hoping that last bit
wasn't terribly mystifying but we've got
basically the problem solved here if we
want to tell whether it's right side up
or upside down without using a built in
API so that's just the very start of it
right so what I've done with this this
is the Excel Mme 84 module on node it's
got more functions than this you can
tell it how fast you want to do it you
can take all these different register
descriptions and break them out into the
JavaScript software they're all like
part of the node API there's just
endless stuff that you can do once
you've gotten your basic information out
of it but that's all I'm gonna do up
here on stage and I hope if you want to
come to the workshop tomorrow I hope you
can come up with some interesting
interpretations we've got sensors that
aren't on pretty breakout boards like
this so you can learn how to do alcohol
sensing and load force and all those
type of stuff that we actually don't
have any node modules for us you'll be
inventing it that's all my demo if you'd
like to look at these slides I actually
have a few other demos that I didn't
show today I showed these ones and if
you want to look at a slower step
through these other ones are available
to you and you can find my slides if you
go to github free whole Singapore demos
oh and I have a book that's recently out
if you'd like to get into it it's not
just tehsil it's all sorts
different boards does anybody have
questions there's no way I explained it
that well yeah
oh do we have a microphone over here so
maybe for the last part when you're
compared is off-site that is up or done
you can just shift the bits seven-digit
just check the most significant
significant bit it's a mental area is
easier to understand that than comparing
with where the binary number
you understand why me yeah you're right
so it depends on what kind of mental
aerobics are easier for you he was
suggesting that instead of comparing
this 0 1 1 1 1 1 number I could just
shift the bits down in order to just get
rid of these extra numbers that I don't
care about yeah for me this was easier
for you it might be it might be easier
to do it a different way and that's kind
of what's fun is if you start with
looking up sensors online you have just
a ton of freedom to to mess around and
decide what implementation you would
like a little bit more time if you have
another pressing question you left
everybody speechless well alright then
I'll expect all of you to make me a
firmware thing tomorrow
go and meet Kelsey afterwards right and
maybe take a look at the hard way
yourself - all right give a round of
applause to Cassie
[Music]
you